eat a delicious meal fit for a crime
lord and cuddle up with your partner
because yes we have the last episode of
star wars content until obi-wan releases
in a few months
the bubalorian or mandalorian season 2.5
has been a wild ride and in this video
we'll be breaking down the episode the
post-credits scene and some of the
details you may have missed along the
way and you'll want to stick around till
the end of the video as i'll be going
over an important clue that i think
tells us where season 3 of the
mandalorian is headed so hit that like
and subscribe button because the back to
tank my girlfriend wants for life day
isn't gonna pay for itself happy life
day the final episode is called in the
name of honor which is pretty ironic
since bounty hunters are considered some
of the most dishonorable people in the
galaxy bounty hunters we don't need that
scum but that's all part of boba fett's
journey turning away from his past life
of killer for hire and turning into an
honorable ruler jabber ruled with fear
i intend to rule with respect but as
boba will learn throughout the season
ruling with respect on tatooine is no
easy task as respect has traditionally
been earned through force if he's going
to successfully overcome his enemies
he'll need to establish dominance
although he's the de facto ruler or
daimyo as he calls it of the tatooine
territories he hasn't earned the respect
of the planet's various ruling families
particularly the three gotras who run
moss espa in the wake of jabba and bib
fortuna's death the city has been
running on a tenuous string of uneasy
alliances and boba hopes to unite these
families under his banner after all as
boba says power
hates a vacuum standing in his way is
the pike syndicate who intend to
continue their operation of the illicit
spice trade
spice sorry wrong franchise at the end
of episode 6 the pipe boss orders the
bombing of garcia flips cantina known as
garcia's sanctuary garcia had been
paying boba and this act becomes a
declaration of war we are at war joining
boba and partner fenix shan is the
mandalorian who we've spent the last two
episodes following he's just come back
from convincing cobb van the sheriff of
freetown formerly mos pelgo to join them
in their crusade against the syndicate
what he doesn't know however is that
cobb was taken down by cad bain
considered one of the best and most
experienced bounty hunters in the galaxy
he's been paid by the pike syndicate to
ensure boba and his team are wiped out
if you stayed and watched the
post-credits scene you'll know that cobb
is still live but we'll get into that in
a bit you might also be asking yourself
what was boba doing these last two
episodes probably learning how to ride
that rancor something that was hinted at
in episode three it is said that the
witches of daphomir even rode them
through the forest and fans rather than
fight this syndicate at his palace boba
chooses to stay and protect the people
of moss espa even if it means half the
city getting totally destroyed kat bane
updates the pike boss who's been in
cahoots with the mayor of moss espa
moches it's here we learned that it was
the pike boss not the nikto raiders who
wiped out the tribe of tuscan raiders
that helped boba survive the unforgiving
desert sands after his escape from the
sarlacc pit meanwhile an x-wing
containing grogu in r2d2 lands at
palymoto's hangar i wonder if this is
the same x-wing we see lifted out of the
ocean off the island of aktu in the rise
of skywalker pelly notices grogu wearing
this bheskar chainmail at the end of
episode 6 luke gave grogu a choice take
the lightsaber and train with him to
become a jedi or take the best car armor
and go back to the mandalorian because
jedi are not allowed to form these
emotional attachments grogu can't take
both so it looks as though grogu has
made his choice this armor was forged
from a bheskar spear that mando got from
ahsoka in season 2 of the mandalorian
because mando has made a truce with the
other families of most espa who have
agreed to remain neutral in his feud
with the syndicate he believes he still
has a chance in fighting the syndicate
off he's ordered the gamoreans the
wookie cressantin and the power rangers
to keep tabs on the various factions of
mos espa in case of a surprise attack
what he doesn't know is that the
families have already betrayed him and
will eventually take up arms and join
the syndicate kantbane and the syndicate
surround boba who offers them an
ultimatum let the spice flow and all
this bloodshed can be avoided and when
boba refuses cad tries a different
approach he tells boba that he was the
one who killed kob vamp and that it was
the syndicate who massacred his tuscan
friends this is all an attempt to throw
boba into an emotional rage hoping this
will make him slip up but boba doesn't
take the bait you're going soft in your
old age and this gets at the core of how
boba has changed he's gone from solo
bounty hunter only caring about himself
to understanding the value of family and
friendship living with the tuscans has
made you soft
no
it's made me strong
you can only get so far without a tribe
ironically it's boba's softness that has
made him strong it has allowed him to
forge friendships that ultimately help
him win his battle over the syndicate
with all three gotras turned against
them and the power of the pike syndicate
at their doorstep boba gives the
mandalorian the opportunity to leave but
remember this episode is all about honor
and the mandalorian gave his word he
would help them out even if it means his
death
you sure you wanna stay
this is the way to buy them time boba
has major domo negotiate their surrender
and i gotta say this guy is probably my
favorite new character in the series i
really hope he comes back he tells the
pikes that he hopes to one day visit the
fabled clips of obadiah which is the
pike homeworld located at the end of the
kessel run but major domo doesn't no no
that this is all a ruse to buy mando and
boba enough time to launch a surprise
attack and in one of the most badass
parts of the episode the two bounty
hunters take on a [ __ ] ton of pike
soldiers using everything from the
mandalorians whistling birds to boba's
knee rockets which were first seen in
action in season 2 of the mandalorian
but the hunters are soon overrun and
when it looks like all is lost the
townsfolk from freetown arrived to save
the day originally they wanted nothing
to do with helping mando but the pikes
just shot their beloved sheriff and
don't want the planet overtaken by these
bad guys you didn't have to come here
yes we did
the planet deserves better joining them
is the wookie chrysanthemum and it's
kind of ironic boba ends up saving him
since the first time they met it was
chris santon who tried to kill him in
the back to tank i owe you a nice long
soak in the back to tank when this is
done but things continue to get worse
with the arrival of two scorpenic droids
they have these almost impenetrable
shields that even mando's darksaber
can't penetrate so while bobo goes off
to get his rank or pelly arrives in a
robo rickshaw with grogu and it's the
reunion we've all been waiting for
mando's just happy grogu got his shirt
now i'm not sure how boba got here so
fast with that rancor but the show goes
full king kong with rancor vs droid
insanity the rancor is able to ragdoll
that droid and weaken the shield enough
for mando to get in there and bust it up
but that still isn't enough the droid
gets the upper hand or should i say claw
and when it looks like mando is done for
grogu uses his force ability to remove
one of its gears buying the rancor
enough time to finish it off on the
other side of town fenik the mods and
freetowners are pinned down by the
second droid and it's here we really get
to see that the pikes might actually
have worse aim than stormtroopers and it
wouldn't be star wars without a
traditional wilhelm screen
while this is happening we have a crazy
showdown between cadbane and boba fett
cad can't seem to wrap his head around
why boba would be helping these people
out this is my city
these are my people
i will not abandon them but cad doesn't
buy it after they fight cat pins boba
down and says you're trying to go
straight
but you've got your father's blood
pumping through your veins
you're a killer of course he's talking
about his father jango fett kad's final
lesson to boba is this look out for
yourself
anything else
is weakness
so it's sweet justice when cat is killed
by boba's gaffy stick one which was
given to him through the bonds of
friendship you might have also noticed
this type of metal plate on cat's head
when his hat is removed in this deleted
scene from the clone wars boba and cat
engaged in a duel which saw both hunters
being shot this would explain both cad's
head plate and the dent in boba's iconic
helmet it just makes this scene all the
more powerful knowing the history these
two have with the second droid destroyed
the ranker goes on a rampage imitating
king kong the mandalorian tries to stop
him almost getting eaten alive in the
process but it's grogu that actually
comes in and saves the day here using
the force to lull the beast into sleep
we've seen grogo use this ability in
season one of the mandalorian it's here
that mando gives grogu the metal ball
from the razor crest you know that one
he always used to play with now check
out these stormtrooper helmets on pikes
a throwback to the mandalorian we're
back in mos eisley where we learn this
syndicate has pulled back from us espa
the families that turned on boba are
upset their deal with the pikes didn't
go the way it was planned the mayor is
also here which is convenient for fenik
shan who puts her assassin skills to the
test and takes them all out life seems
to go back to normal and for the first
time it appears as though the people of
tatooine finally respect boba giving him
a symbolic melon
i just love the added touch of the
people picking up rocks and debris from
the battle that completely decimated
their city it's uncertain whether boba
will spend the rest of his time ruling
over tatooine he says he's not suited
for this but as fennec reminds him if
they aren't going to run this place then
who so it leaves room open for a season
2 but the way this show played out i got
the feeling this was more of a limited
series acting as a bridge to the
mandalorian season 3 which is convenient
because the show ends on mando and grogu
on his new ship and i just love how
grogu has his own little dome now you
may be asking yourself where is mando
off to and i think episode 5 gives us a
clue as to where season 3 of the
mandalorian is headed when mando defeats
paz vizsla and a duel for the darksaber
the armorer asks mando if he's ever
taken off his helmet which he responds
truthfully with a yes this is against
their creed and the armorer announces
then you are a mandalorian no more mando
asks if there's any way he can atone to
which she says according to creed one
may only be redeemed in the living
waters beneath the minds of mandalore
this is where i think he's headed
mandalore in order to regain his title
of mandalorian remember that he also has
the darksaber and it is said whoever
wields it can lead all of mandalore
mandalore was purged by the emperor
during the night of a thousand tears so
just what state this planet is in isn't
entirely known there will however be
someone after the mandalorians darksaber
and that's bo katan who believes she has
a rightful claim to lead mandalore there
is something i need if i am to rule
mandalore something that was once mine
they know where it is and soon so will i
so definitely count on a confrontation
between mando and bo catan we also have
a post-credit scene which shows us the
fate of cobb van boba tells us that
someone is using his back to tank and i
guess we now know who it is alongside
him is the mod specialist boba paid
years ago to save fenik shan's life by
turning her into a cyborg he shows off
one of his tools as if he's getting
ready to work on cobb this likely means
that cobb will be indebted to boba and
if boba's story continues this could
have far reaching implications cobb
would also make for an honorable ruler
in boba's dead should he venture away
from tatooine but i want to hear what
you thought about the book of boba fett
and where you think this story is headed
leave your thoughts and theories in the
comments below thanks for watching
everyone make sure to like and subscribe
and for more bad takes you can follow me
on twitter and instagram at thingstoryt
until next time remember i am boba fett
[Music]